from Stillman Douglas high school in
parkland Florida to Manhattan New York
as a student I am sick and tired of
being forced to be on high alert to
Littleton Colorado site of the Columbine
massacre and in the heart of the
nation's capitol students walked out of
classrooms across the country to protest
gun violence and demands safer schools
and stricter gun control laws and also
to pay 17 minutes a tribute to the 17
students and staff killed at Stoneman
Douglas on Valentine's Day one month ago
we the students of the United States
have a message for all of you in
Congress if you don't give us stricter
background checks you will pay dearly at
the ballot box in Washington students
turned their backs on the White House
and we're joined outside the Capitol by
lawmakers walking out in solidarity you
know we are grieving in Florida and now
you are giving voice to that grief we're
gonna win we're gonna win in Fort
Lauderdale the confessed killer and the
Stoneman Douglas massacre was back in
court shackled head down staring and
saying nothing during his arraignment
Nicolas Cruz is charged with 17 counts
of first degree murder and 17 counts of
attempted murder prosecutors want the
death penalty Cruz's attorneys are
offering to plead guilty to everything
if the death penalty is taken off the
table at this point that's not happening
so the judge pleaded not guilty for him
and this afternoon the Coral Springs
Police Department released new 911 ate
by students and teachers from inside
Stoneman Douglas as the rampage was
happening and the terror was raw cookies
what he got shot in the chest
also in the courtroom today Cruz's
eighteen-year-old younger brother
biological brothers Zachary who was also
adopted at Birth by the same couple he
sat in the courtroom and cried at the
gravity VAT all listened to the
attorneys and the judge talked about the
real possibility now that Nicholas Cruz
gets executed
Brett Phil Keating in Fort Lauderdale
Phil thanks